new report from Maggie Haberman of the
New York Times is that Donald Trump is
furious over his humiliating losses on
Tuesday is tantruming like a child and
blaming everyone around him even his
wife Melania check out these tweets from
the New York times's Maggie Haberman
quote Trump is indeed Furious this
morning particularly about Mehmet Oz and
is blaming everyone who advised him to
back Oz including his wife
describing it as not her best decision
according to people close to him now
there is truth to the fact
as I said earlier that if Trump had gone
with David McCormick rather than Mehmet
Oz in the Pennsylvania Republican
primary McCormick probably would have
won he only lost by 951 votes he
probably would have won I do think
Trump's endorsement gained Oz a little
over 900 votes that's totally plausible
had McCormick won
you might have had a completely
different situation in Pennsylvania
because there were Republicans who said
Oz this guy's a clown he's not even from
Pennsylvania this doesn't make any sense
now Trump saying Melania was one of the
people that told him to do that that's
pretty interesting Maggie Haberman
continuing quote there are people
pushing Trump to reschedule his
announcement next week and several
Republicans have texted asking whether
he will but it's risky and would be
acknowledging he's wounded by yesterday
something that some advisors insist is
not the case this is the point about
narcissism that I made a narcissist you
know we many of us
who don't have these personality
Tendencies we sometimes trick ourselves
into believing you know what this guy
who can't ever just admit you know what
I got I got outrun I straight up lost
once it's verified and and validated
that Joe Biden won and Biden's
inaugurated Trump's not going to have
any choice but to say you know what I
lost and we were wrong it's two years
later and Trump is still saying it was
stolen in my personal life I've had
situations with
um oftentimes it's with pathological
Liars who sometimes are also extreme
narcissists we're in my head I go wow at
this point they're not going to be able
to keep up the lie anymore they're going
to have to just say you know what I made
that up
and they never do they find a way around
it and the way that this applies to
Trump is we all see Tudor Dixon Mehmet
Oz uh Doug mastriano we don't know yet
about Carrie leg you know we're still
counting all
it wasn't a good night for Trump's
critical contested endorsements he has
no choice at this point to just say wow
I really messed up right no he's blaming
his wife he's potentially going forward
with this completely harebrained
announcement on Tuesday all right last
tweet from Maggie Haberman quote worth
remembering Trump is a grown man who
endorsed Oz Over the objection of some
of the people closest to him and instead
went beyond just endorsing and attacked
Dave McCormick from the stage at a rally
yeah it's important to remember we're
dealing with a nearly 80 year old man
it's my wife's fault
that's what he's going with it's
completely pathetic and ridiculous now
the question is does he heed the calls
to delay the announcement one of our
sponsors is all form the easiest way to
design your own custom sofa I have one
from all form unlike other companies all
form lets you choose the fabric the size
the shape color even the color of the
legs I have not one but two all form
sofas I've had them for years they look
good as new definitely the most
comfortable Furniture I own and it gets
even cooler because all form sofas are
completely modular you can buy a sofa
and if you move you can adapt it to the
new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and armchairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below